hello and welcome to this video this is
kit drill
it's the opponent and I'm trying out a
Dutch defense let's see I see it gets we
get this kind of setup looks a lot like
in names aware was a hybrid between the
Dutch and him so f5 kind of fits into
this position so oh yeah cheeks
voluntarily so it's surprising I would
have actually thought about provoking
that with aged six but wasn't necessary
okay now he's sitting himself up for the
fork okay so we can't yet to save it I
had to save the bishop um yeah a couple
of ways to play this position problem
put the night here I wonder if it is
actually a good idea to play this
typical newman's away it would be six
and Bishop a six here or if this is not
the best I think I'd like to get a lot
of potential checks first and then
consider my options I can also just
bring this Knight over to the other side
of the board
okay I need this probably anyway to move
my bishop yeah now yeah hmm if I go
Knight a5 he might take and flame Queen
to d5 well and it's not a big problem
but I'm not sure that I want those
trades so I'm going back to East 7
keeping d5 covered
maybe I'll just play Bishop b7 and claim
that this is a good diagonal which is
probably a justified claim and that
wouldn't be unhappy at all if he would
push d5 okay this is now entirely
irrelevant after he went to c5 it looks
like an interesting move by the way kir
solvents develop this
still have the slightly more comfortable
pawn structure here there is the C pawn
that I can potentially attack okay um a
couple of options even this is a way to
play threatening a forward f3 for a
direct attack it's it's playable at
least that also opens up f5 for the
night I mean as I mentioned there is the
half-open C file and I can play against
the pawn but I can also just go for an
attack and given the choice between some
strategic play and attacking the king
you should always almost always choose
the king it's just more dangerous like
it's nice to win a pawn somewhere and so
on it if you can checkmate the guy it's
just better yeah here I think this looks
nice yeah how does he play him it's not
easy
92 rook t8 looks awful and do you want
to have your pawn structure completely
destroyed I have three probably not also
I've got Luke f6 g6 these ideas now he
will he takes a while it's not easy to
even make a move that doesn't even make
it worse I mean I might as well just
take twice on f3 in winner porn it's
also an issue and it's almost not
avoidable almost unavoidable by now
you know so what to do now
rook the age is probably a good move
getting an additional piece into the
play and how where's the Queen going
yeah but Luke did to wheel and now is
there anything better than taking
probably not and it is pretty strong I'm
threatening like everything made the the
rook is hanging okay so here probably
rook g2 is killing yeah
Piru gave three is devastating
threatening everything Ruka have one
double-check made and so on it's just no
move
yeah couldn't do anything against it I
was a pretty yeah white White's position
out of the opening was really not so
attractive I decided to take on c3 while
it was still on giving the doubled pawn
if I play I mean I can apply castles or
something but he at least then it has
this move to cover c3 that was very
surprised that he took on f6 because
that is absolutely not necessary at this
particular moment
you can play III or something normal at
same and they're giving me their let's
say voluntarily giving up the bishop
pair doesn't help okay Bishop d3 d5
Bishop c2 and now not quite sure but
knight c6 looks fine I'm covering e5
there was the idea to capture and play
Queen d5 chicken winning the a pawn so I
had to cover it I guess castles and now
I was a little bit yeah it's a bit of a
lazy move King h8 but it's a think quite
reasonable
so no checks anywhere on d5 will be
three will be one year be six I can't
have to play we should it form you know
97 I think is sensible this this looks a
little bit like after this it looks a
little bit yeah it doesn't look optimal
that same I don't want to give up if I
foresee form and I did not consider a
four-year as the engine does
this is interesting and probably indeed
good for Blackfoot 97's keep it simple
you know the night is heading towards
the kingside it had c5 and the engine
suggests to simply take the pawn yeah
but Bishop e7 is a good move my soul
took it look see one now yeah a force
maybe not the best rook c8 is the normal
movement f4 I just tried to play in a
powerful way a threatening efore f3
going for the attack
and the engines suggestion of efore
shows that f4 is at least from a
practical point of view a strong
decision because if is not a very human
move to make and in fact I don't quite
understand why this is anything you know
maybe from practical terms even if you
if you look at it this is basically a
pawn and just for not much but so can
you trade a bit mem you don't get
checkmated immediately yeah D takes e5
gives me the D file and it takes F is
probably losing ok so I should go E for
the same ideas before and now Queen
takes wasn't even best okay rook th yeah
okay that is a decent move to flick em
now rook the 8th
it's just winning the house
yeah that's an easy win at the end yeah
okay guys thanks for watching